العدل الامريكي تحقق في اعتراف تكتب
بالتجسس على صحفيين واللاعب المعتقل بتهمه
الاغتصاب داني يضرب عن الطعام وهيئه
الترفيه تحتفل ب 120 مليون زائر
لفعالياتها اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
البدايه من الصراع الامريكي الصيني وحلقه
جديده من حلقاتها حيث تم الكشف عن تحقيق
لوزاره العدل الامريكيه في تجسس التيك توك
على مواطنين امريكيين ومن بينهم صحفيون
التحقيق مر عليه شهور لكن الكشف عنه تم
الان فالقضيه تعود ديسمبر الماضي حين نشرت
تقارير عن تجسس تيك توك على مواطنين
امريكيين ومن بينهم صحفي في
موقع باسفيد وموظفين يعملون معهم وكشفت
التقارير عن وصول تيك توك لمعلومات شخصيه
عن المواطنين الامريكيين ليست هذه المره
الاولى التي تتهم فيها امريكا تيك توك
بالتجسس لكن اللافت كان اعتراف تيك توك
حينها بالواقعه الشركات قالت ان موظفين
قاموا بالوصول للمعلومه بطرق غير سليمه
واعلنت طردهم من مواقعهم الحديث عن هذا
الاعتراف الخطير عاد اليوم للاخبار ان بعد
انباء عن تحقيق وزاره العدل يوم الخميس
جدد التيك توك تصريحات حول الواقعه وجددت
التذكير بطرد الموظفين المتورطين في
التجسس وقالت ان تحقيقا داخليا في الامر
مستمر وستعلن عن نتائجه فور انتهاء منهم
هذه الحلقه الجديده من الازمه تاتي في وقت
التوتر الصيني الامريكي في اشده وخاصه ملف
تيك توك فمن اسابيع حضرت الولايات المتحده
استعمل تيك توك على الاجهزه الرسميه وعلى
كل موظفي الحكومه ولحقها في القرار دول
غربيه عده كلها كانت دافعها المخاوف على
الامن القومي والذي تصر التيك توك على
انها مخاوف غير مبرره يوجد اي دليل عليها
ومن ايام قال تقرير لويسري جورنال ان
الحكومه الامريكيه طلبت من شركه بايت دانز
المالكه لتيك توك ومقرها الصين طلبت منها
بيع اسهمها في تيك توك او مواجهه حظره في
الولايات المتحده
ينضم الينا عبر زوم من دبي المختص في
التكنولوجيا كريم فريد اهلا بك كريم لماذا
فتحت القضيه من جديد الان نعرف ان هذه
التحقيقات كانت قد فتحت وفي ديسمبر الماضي
واعلن عن نتائجها لماذا تم فتحها الان
وتحركت وزاره العدل الامريكيه في ازاء هذا
الموضوع من جديد الان
في التسعينات تقريبا كان في كرتون بيتعرض
باستمرار وفي فرين الفرين كل يوم فار منهم
اللي هو اللي مش زاكي قوي يقول للفرد تاني
ماذا سنفعل اليوم يا برين والتاني يقول له
سنحاول السيطره على العالم انا حاسس ان كل
حاجه لها علاقه بتيك توك اشبه بالسيناريو
اللي بيحصل بشكل يومي بقى لنا شهور بنسمع
نفس التهديدات نفس نفس المعلومات تقريبا
بتتكرر ولغايه النهارده مفيش موقف فعلي
جدي من الحكومه الامريكيه باذاء تيك توك
في الشركه عبر بتجسس بتجسسها او تجسس
موظفين فيها على مواطنين امريكيين على
صحتهم وهي حاجه بتهدد حريه
المعلومات وبتهدد حريه التعبير
الحكومه الامريكيه عاده بتدعي انها بتدافع
عنها بقوه فلماذا يعني ما خدتش موقف جد
واكثر قوه نقدر نقول من مجرد التهديدات في
الحقيقه ما فيش حد عنده معلومه حقيقيه ايه
اللي بيحصل وزاره العدل هذه المره اليس
جديا بشكل كافي
الرئيس الامريكي بنفسه اتحرك في مواقف سبا
وتمت مفاوضات وخلافات وغيره وبناء عليها
تم نقل المعلومات المواطنين الامريكيين
حسب تيك توك وقتها لشركات او لسيرفرات
امريكيه على ارض امريكيه فبالتالي الموضوع
مستمر من فتره وفي نفس الوقت بالتوازي
شركات تكنولوجيه كتير امريكيه زي فيسبوك
مثلا حاولت ثنائي حاولت منافسه تيك توك في
ملعبها بطرح محتوى مشابه مشابهه وهكذا
ولكن للاسف فيسبوك ويوتيوب الاتنين حاولوا
وما قدروش ان هم يتحوجوا على
المستقبل موظفيها على التجسس على امريكيين
وعلى مستخدمين الا يضعف موقفها في هذه
القضيه
بكل تاكيد بكل تاكيد
الغريب غريب جدا في الموضوع الاعتراف وفي
نفس الوقت الاغرب هو عدم تحرك الحكومه
الامريكيه بشكل جاد وبرد اكثر قوه بعد
الاعتراف فايه
الان خيرت تيك توك بين بيع الشركه او
حظرها او حظرها
واعتقد ان الاغلب اللي هيحصل هو بيع
الشركه لاوتر او طرحها في البورصه لشركات
امريكيه لان على الرغم من ان التيك توك
عليه مستخدمين كثير ولكن
هيكون المالك الجديد صيني او ايضا ولا
حتبيع لشركات انترناشونال
بحاله طرح في البورصه واعتقد دي المعلومات
المتداوله
مالكين عده او شركاء في الشركه من جنسيات
مختلفه مكان الطرح هيكون هو السؤال الابرز
لو الطرح في البورصه الامريكيه اعتقد ممكن
الامريكيه للتغاضي عن حاجات تانيه كتير في
مقابل ضخ اموال وسيوله في البورصه
الامريكيه
ليس لديها القدره بيع او طرح اصومها من
دون اذن الصينيه وكل تاكيد
هذا لا يعرضها لادانه انه هي مرتبطه بشكل
مباشر الى السلطات الصينيه كما تقول
تتهمها امريكا
كلنا عارفين ان هي مرتبطه
بالسلطات الصينيه
وتؤكد في نفس الوقت ولكن زيها زي حاجات
تانيه كتير احنا كلنا عارفين بس ما بنقولش
ده مباشره الحكومه الامريكيه عارفه بس ما
بتقولش ده مباشره هي تاني تيك توك بتلعب
دور كبير في الازمه الاكبر الدايره بين
الحكومه الامريكيه والحكومه الصينيه لها
علاقه بالنفوس بالسيطره بالتكنولوجيا
بحركه راس المال وبالمنافسه الاقتصاديه
بشكل كبير فهنا نقدر نقول ان تيك توك مجرد
يعني حجر صغير في هرم كبير هل هل هتقدر
تاثر بالتاكيد هتاثر بشكل كبير لان تيك
توك ادى للصين قدره على المنافسه او ان هو
قوه ناعمه للصين ما كانتش موجوده عندها
قبل كده في التواصل مع العالم الخارجي
بلغته فهل الحكومه الصينيه هتفرط في مصدر
قوه ناعمه زي تيك توك او
ده اللي محتاجين نشوفه خلال الفتره الجايه
ولكن انتصار الحكومه الامريكيه في ازمه
تيك توك ممكن يكون يغير في شكل الصراع
الداير حاليا
كان معنا المختص في التكنولوجيا كريم فريد
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
وكتبت ترامب في منشوره عن فساد التحقيق
بهذه القضيه التي وصفها بالخرافيه
والمكشوفه بالكامل وقال ان المحكمه تم
تمويلها بشكل كبير من قبل جورج سورس رجل
الاعمال الامريكي المعروف بعدائيته واذا
كانت مزاعم ترامب بشان توقيف وشيك صحيحه
فستكون هذه السابقه وهي اول مره من نوعها
لرئيس سابق يواجه اتهامات جنائيه كانت
ترامب نشر البوست بعد ساعات من تداول
انباء بان المدعي العام لمقاطعه منهات
يخطط لتوجيه لائحه اتهامات ضده الاسبوع
المقبل منشور ترامب اثر جدلا ونقاشا واسعا
اضطرت بعضها محاميته للتوضيح في بيان قالت
فيه ان الرئيس السابق لم يكتب منشوره مع
علم مباشر بتوقيت اي اعتقال وقالت محاميته
للترامب ان منشوره استند الى تقارير
اخباريه متهمه مكتب المدعي العام في
منهاتم باجراء محاكمه سياسيه
كثيرون اقلقهم منشور ترامب واعلانه
وتذكروا تغريدته التي دعا فيها انصاره
للاحتجار وقال ان الانتخابات سرقت منه
واعتبرت التغريده تحريض على الاحتجاجات
التي انتهت التي انتهت باحداث الشغب في
الكابيتول كما نتذكر وكم علق كثيرون على
الانباء متسائلين ان كان فعلا سيعتقل ومات
داعي ذلك ومن المعلقين كان الملياردير
الذي كتب على تويتر ان انه اذا تم توجيه
الاتهام الى ترامب رسميا فستتم اعاده
انتخاب تروم بانتصار ساحق في عام 2024
وكمان اسم المرشح للرئاسه في عام 2024
تروم يتصدر الاخبار ايضا بسبب تطورات اخرى
فشركه يوتيوب اعلنت اعاده تفعيل حسابه من
بعد مرور عامين على حظره وعبر تغريده على
تويتر اعلنت يوتيوب انه لم تعد قناه دونا
مقيده ويمكنها تحميل محتوى جديد وانه تم
تقييم المخاطر وان القرار هو من باب اعطاء
فرص متكافئه لكل المرشحين الفتره المقبله
وفي تغريده ثانيه قالت يوتيوب ان قناه
ترامب ستبقى خاضعه لسياساتها مثل اي قناه
اخرى وللتذكير فقد كان تم اعاده حسابات
ترامب على تويتر وفيسبوك وانستجرام من
اشهر وامس فورا استخدم يوتيوب حيث يملك
اكثر من مليونين مشترك وحمل اول فيديو كما
نشاره نفسه على فيسبوك ايضا الذي يتابعه
عليه 34 مليون شخص ورساله ترامب في
المنصات في المنصتين كانت لقد عدت
شعري
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اخبار جديده اليوم
نسمعها عن لاعب كره القدم داني الفيش
المتهم بقضيه اغتصاب فتاه في ملهى ليلي في
برشلونه والذي وضع في السجن رهن الاحتجاز
من 20 يناير ورفض القاضي الافراج عنه
بكفاله اكثر من مره الى حين الحكم المحكمه
وللتذكير وضع داني في القضيه ليس جيدا
خاصه بعد ان غير اقواله اربع مرات وتخلى
نادي عنه وفسخ تعاقده معه اما زوجته فبعد
ان اعلنت دعمها له بدايه عادت وطلبت
الطلاق منه يبدو بعد تاكدها من تورطه في
القضيه الجديد اليوم هو انباء عن دخول
داني الفيش في اضراب عن الطعام حزنا على
طلب زوجته بالطلاق المعلومات تقول ان
اللاعب متوتر وعصبي وحزين ويرفض الطعام
منذ زياره زوجته الاخيره له في فبراير
واخبارها له وجها لوجه بنيتها انهاء
الزواج
هي عارضه ازياء وزوجه داني وكانت كما قلنا
سندته بدايه لكنها عادت سريعا وطلبت الطلق
ومن ايام نشرت بوست على حسابها على
انستجرام قالت ان الاشهر الماضيه كانت
مروعه جدا ومن اصعب ايام حياتها وان داني
الفيش كان شريكا مثاليا وانها لا تصدق ان
شخصا احبته بكل صدق قادر على تحطيمها بهذا
الشكل وان الامل سيستغرق سنوات حتى تنسى
ما حصل جوا قالت انها انسانه مستقله وذكيه
ومراعيه ومخلصه ولانها كل ذلك فستبقى
بجانب دانيال وانما بصوره مختلفه وانهت
حديثها بانها الان تختتم مرحله من حياتها
بدات في مايو 2018 وهو تاريخ زواجها من
داني وانها امراه تتحضر للانتقال من مرحله
لاخرى من حياتها
شهدت محافظه اربيل في كردستان العراق مره
يوم الجمعه بمشاركه العشرات من المواطنين
والى جانب المواطنين المشاركين كان هناك
ضيف لم يتوقعه احد فاجا الجميع
[موسيقى]
خلال عطله نهايه الاسبوع اعلن رئيس هيئه
الترفيه المستشار تركي ال الشيخ وصول عدد
حضور الفعاليات العامه والخاصه 120 مليون
زائر المستشار في تغريدته قال ان هذا
الانجاز ياتي بدعم من الملك سلمان وولي
العهد محمد بن سلمان القائد الملهم وعراب
الرؤيه المباركه ولفت المستشار الى ان عدد
الزوار هذا من يناير 2019 الى اليوم اي مع
فتره كورونا الصعبه
وبمناسبه حديثنا عن فعاليات السعوديه
فعطله نهايه الاسبوع كانت حافله
بالفعاليات لكن حفلتين سيطرتا على
العناوين واصداؤها ملات المنصات اكثر من
غيرها نبدا من نهار الجمعه مع الفنانه
انغام التي احيت حفلا على مسرح ابو بكر
سالم في الرياض بعنوان ليله صوت مصر انغام
غنت على مدار اكثر من اربع ساعات اجمل ما
غنت في تاريخها وكان معها على المسرح
والكسره كامله بقياده المايسترو هاني
فرحات
البعيد الهادي
[موسيقى]
وفي نفس المكان
فنان
انا
مستنيه اجمل حبيب في عينيا مش ده اللي
بتقوله عليا انا
[موسيقى]
من غيرك او بيك
وشو في حياتي عليك
وهعيش وبع
[موسيقى]
الكفوفنا واحد
مو على
[موسيقى]
حفل الفنانه انغام كان في الكثير من
المفاجات ايضا فالى جانب الحضور الكبير من
مشاهير حضروا الحفل لدعمها والاحتفال فيها
شاركها على المسرح نجوم كانوا مفاجاه
للجمهور وصعدوا بعض الاغاني معها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كتير بالي عليك مشغول
عليا حالي وانا بكتبلك
كلامي
ومش مب
سوط واحلف بتحب مش مشروب
[موسيقى]
ولا انساك عشان ارتاح
وعمال قلبي
بي وحتى الصبر مش نافع انا مش عارفه اعمل
ايه
ويوم
جراحي تزيد ويكبر شوقي جوالك ما ترحمني
[ضحك]
تعبت خلاص من اللي انا فيه
[موسيقى]
حفله وانغام كانت الجمعه اما السبت فاحيا
فنان العرب محمد عبده احيا امس سهره
استثنائيه مليئه بالطرب الاصيل ضمن جلسات
ليالي الرياض وبالطبع وكما المعتاد اسم
فنان العرب و هاشتاج باسم الحفل تفضلوا
المنصات ومحركات البحث ومقاطع الحفل كانت
الاكثر مشاهده نحن وصلنا لنهايه الحلقه
ساترككم مع مقاطع منحه فنان العرب الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ته
والصبر انا تجرع
نا
را اخضر في
حقها
[موسيقى]
والعفو عند القدره
اراك عصيه
[موسيقى]
شيمتك الصبر
اماني الهوى
عليك
ولا امر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
تدرب عذابي
عذاب الحب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وتصبح على
[موسيقى]